do you experience bloating i know i did
for many many years it was very very
uncomfortable
it seemed like almost everything i ate i
was i felt like i was pregnant and it
was very difficult to sleep it was
difficult to constantly suck in my
stomach to try to avoid anyone knowing
that i was actually
bloated so this is what you need to know
about bloating there are many different
causes of bloating okay there's not just
one cause so i'm going to go through all
the causes but there's a real simple
thing you can do to identify
where it's coming from okay number one
take a look at when you started getting
bloating okay was it yesterday was it
today
what time did you start getting bloating
and then what did you eat right before
was it the obvious junk food or
processed food was it sugar alcohols
let's say you started the ketogenic diet
and you had some i don't know xylitol
erythritol or mannitol whatever and then
that created the bloating because that
was new okay
or you saw in one of my videos that i
recommended consuming seven to ten cups
of salad and now you're bloating okay or
was it that cruciferous vegetable that
you normally don't consume
and then you start getting bloated or
maybe it was dairy okay that's a common
cause of bloating or you bought a keto
snack or a keto bar that had corn fiber
for example which was a new ingredient
that you added to your diet and now
you're pregnant well guess what all you
need to do is just avoid that thing and
you're not going to bloat anymore or
like in practice i had this one lady who
came in and she says i'm bloating like
i'm pregnant and then she came in the
following day
and guess what she was pregnant so
you're bloating could be that you're
pregnant but very simply just find out
when you're bloating what did you
introduce that was new
and just avoid that thing but let's say
you have bloating is there anything you
could do to get rid of the bloating yes
there is so if this is the right side of
the underneath the rib cage and this is
your left side right through like this
you simply could massage
the two key parts of your digestive
system that are many times responsible
for bloating one is the gallbladder on
the right side or it could be the
pancreas which i'm going to talk about
so what you're going to do is you just
kind of start massaging right underneath
the rib cage okay and i like to just
press about an inch off the midline to
the right and about an inch down from
your rib cage maybe two inches down and
press right into that area
and just kind of massage to the left and
the right and just kind of hold this
point for about one to two minutes just
don't use this a sharp object when
you're pressing in here you can use a
massage tool or the end of some
dull
piece of wood but don't use a sharp
object okay and then you just kind of
work on the left side and you start
massaging these two areas and you're
going to help kind of decongest these
organs and get rid of a lot of bloating
and it'll either push
gas through or
fluid now one side note i want to
mention
uh one of my patients
noticed that
their constant bloating went away when
they went down to florida and laid on
the beach okay and that was because this
person was going through a massive
stress
and every time they experience sun
and the reduction of cortisol stress
their stomach reduced to the point where
it was flat and that is because cortisol
or stress creates inflammation and
swelling in the midsection okay so
that's just a side note if you notice
that you go through a stress event and
you notice your stomach is distended
especially as the day goes on but let's
go through each organ and talk about the
potential cause of your bloating let's
start with the stomach here
if the stomach does not have enough acid
or the ph of the stomach is too alkaline
okay because you're taking antacids or
whatever you can experience either acid
reflux okay or gerd
or heartburn
or indigestion indigestion is a real
good clue that you don't have enough
acid in your stomach
or bloating okay
so if you have bloating
and you have indigestion or acid reflux
then it's more likely that it's coming
from the stomach the thing about the
stomach is it's one of the first places
to help you start to digest okay and if
you don't have enough acid like a lot of
people
from that point on the food stuff will
kind of go through this whole chain of
events and if it's undigested here it's
going to be undigested here and these
organs are going to have to work harder
so it's very important to have enough
acid in your stomach to start the
process of breaking down the protein
especially with the right amount of acid
okay so if you need acid what you can do
is
take something called betaine
hydrochloride
it comes in a supplement and you would
take maybe five or six of these with a
meal and that's going to greatly help
the stomach regain its acid
the other thing you could take is apple
cider vinegar either on an empty stomach
or
with food so you would take one or two
tablespoons and some water and that will
help your digestion okay so that would
be the stomach
the next thing i want to talk about is
the gallbladder the purpose of the
gallbladder is to concentrate
bile
which is like a detergent that helps you
break down fat
by a factor of 5x so it helps to
concentrate the bile so when you eat
it's released into the small intestine
and it mixes with the pancreatic enzymes
to help you break down certain things
okay
now if the gallbladder does not have
enough bile
maybe you don't have a gallbladder or
maybe it's just sluggish
you'll get burping
belching
or bloating
or you'll feel
nauseated and there's a lot of symptoms
but you can feel bloating if you don't
have enough bile salts okay
so if you bloat and you have this
belching and burping and maybe you have
a
a full sensation underneath the right
rib cage or you have pain that's going
into the right shoulder right through
here it could be up up back through here
it could be up here
or in your neck
then suspect gallbladder and then you
need some purified bile salts or
gallbladder formula to help assist
this gallbladder so that would be some
clues that it could be that you need
help right through in here the other
thing you can do
and you can use this also to help figure
out if it is the gallbladder is just
press underneath the right rib cage you
start massaging underneath the right rib
cage and if your discomfort on the right
side goes away or you feel less bloating
chances are
it could be that you just need a little
help with more bile salts all right now
we have the pancreas right pancreas is
more on the left side but it does cross
over a little bit to the center maybe to
the right side
but if your pancreas needs help let's
say you don't have enough enzymes okay
because of various reasons maybe you're
diabetic or you've eaten a lot of carbs
in the past and
you're getting a loss of function in the
pancreas the pancreas just makes enzymes
you could get diarrhea
you can get floating stool like kind of
like a greasy stool that floats that
means you don't have enough enzymes to
break down that fat it's called lipase
and guess what you're going to get a lot
of bloating if this is the case okay
you need more enzymes so you'd want to
get some supplement that has a wide
variety of enzymes you also want to make
sure that you consume
food with enzymes maybe some raw like
salads okay to get more enzymes to help
you digest as well as fermented food
like sauerkraut things like that would
help take the pressure off the pancreas
the pancreas also improves when you cut
down the high carbs okay because the
more sugar you have the more insulin
that's produced the more the pancreas
has to work harder
so that's the pancreas okay so with the
stomach you need more acid
the gallbladder bile with the pancreas
enzymes moving right along we have this
thing called the small intestine which
is right in the center
the small intestine is where you have 90
of all the digestion okay
and so the food particles that are
broken down by the stomach into amino
acids the gallbladder breaking down the
fat the the pancreas helping breaking
down food and then the small intestine
which also has enzymes but it's not
supposed to have a lot of bacteria
a lot of the bacteria the good bacteria
should be in this large intestine okay
further down but you have this long pipe
that the food should go through
and the enzymes and other things should
act on the food to break it down and
then help it be absorbed so it can go in
through the liver and other places in
the body but
a lot of people
get bloating in the small intestine okay
they actually have
fermentation going on in the small
intestine fermentation
is the action of a microbe on a food
like a carbohydrate a fiber or sugar
okay
now an example of this would be
with my chickens okay so i have about 16
chickens and we eat their eggs and what
i do is i ferment the food okay the when
you ferment the food you actually soak
it in water for three days and the
bacteria that's normally in the grains
and which by the way the organic grains
is going to act on the carbohydrate
break them down and make it much easier
for the chicken to digest that food
plus in the fermentation process you get
a lot of
gases that are released like carbon
dioxide as you can see in this image
right here we have a lot of carbon
dioxide and other gases being produced
by the microorganisms
it looks like it's boiling but it's just
releasing gas but guess what when you
have this excess
fermentation going on in your small
intestine
that gas is going to produce a lot of
distension and bloating
so
you could have either
fluid retention okay going on the small
intestine
or
gas
because if you're not able to digest
certain foods in the small intestine
you're going to retain fluid and that's
one version of bloating but it can also
be a combination of gas as well so
this condition in the small intestine is
called sibo small intestinal bacterial
overgrowth okay this is a situation
where you have
bacteria that normally should be in the
large intestine but it's in the small
intestine it's in the wrong place and
the food coming down is being fermented
in the wrong place and you're going to
get a lot of gas and fluid retention and
how do we know you have
sibo well if you consume
probiotics
guess what you're going to feel worse
you're going to get more bloating or if
you consume more salad or fiber
it's going to be worse you're going to
get more bloating why because you have
these bacteria that are ready to
ferment it and at this level and you're
going to feel worse if you consume that
so that's one indication to know that
potentially you have sibo you can go get
a test
so what do you do if you have sibo well
you want to avoid
probiotics
and you want to avoid fiber so you
probably want to do
carnivore for a while which means you're
not going to be consuming any
plant fiber okay any vegetables for a
while maybe one or two months to reset
your system the other thing you should
take is oregano and garlic to act as
a natural antibiotic you can also do
clove and thyme and even sage things
like that and that will act as a natural
antibiotic but these two work really
good
another really important thing to do
would be fasting intermittent fasting
fast as long as you can that will help
to reset and clean this out
okay so that's the small intestine
all right
now we're at the large intestine you can
also have excessive amounts of
fermentation going on giving you
bloating and gas
if you have this situation
it could be you just have an imbalance
in microbes and you have the wrong
amount of certain microbes versus the
other in which case
a wide range of vegetables might be
helpful
more fiber
a lot of people that i know that have
problems down here have like rarely have
any vegetables in fact the average
person consumes i think a cup and a half
of vegetables every single day it's just
not enough so the the microbes live on
the fiber but if you're not feeding them
on a regular basis they might not grow
to the the amount that you want or to
the diversity that you need
so a probiotic
and fiber would be beneficial for this
situation so
if you feel better when you take
a probiotic or fiber or a combination
like sauerkraut has good bacteria and
fiber if you feel better when you take
that chances are your problem is in the
large intestine if you feel worse when
you consume sauerkraut chances are you
might have a problem in the small
intestine okay so that's just a way to
differentiate those two but anyway i
wanted to go through the whole system to
help you understand the different
parts of this digestive system and the
potential cause
of your bloating so you can fully
eliminate it now the other thing i want
to mention
if you're not on healthy keto and you're
not doing intermittent fasting
i would first
go for that implement that before you
even get into any of these things
because you just might need to have the
correct eating plan and the correct time
of eating to correct the whole thing
so if you want that information i put a
very simple playlist you can learn this
very quickly right here check it out
you